Chi vincerà Sanremo Emma Marrone jelier
Pia così posso farle qualche domanda sul
Festival di Sanremo lo odio Emma la sied
ma non è la Sad i santi francesi Allora
se sono santi mi piacciono questi sono
quelli che mi fanno paura non è
l'inferno quattro Mengoni Non lo
possiamo più tifare Ma lo potete
ammirare i santi francesi in Francia non
ce ne sono santi volevo ballare con lui
yeah non lo Sacci proprio chi è un
attore Chi è tuo ragazzo bravo Ha
indovinato che ne St c'è bei gusti sono
qui A pazz con te eh Poi c'è San
Giovanni pure lui ma l'evangelista Santi
francesi e amiamo la Francia amo Parigi
del Il tre non li conosco Renga e f Io
sono Tony Lambretta un Maranza che
balbetta sei un Maranza Sì un Maranza un
camionista Maranza però di quelli bravi
di quelli buoni